hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast innovation lab automation
the future of computational biology it
is presented by mark singer an analyst
at innovation lab I am Judy O'Rourke of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming mark
Binger I will now turn the presentation
over to him and the computational
biology I knew blurr and in the future
of that is because so much of what we
know in competition biology today isn't
directly accessible to our senses it's
not easy to do in a replicable manner
and our tools are really really critical
to how this field advances and this time
advances in the field have been bringing
up new things to measure a new important
phenomena that have driven the evolution
of the tools themselves so there's a lot
going on if if I were to break this down
what's driving innovation and lab
automation it really comes found it to a
few enablers so one is just
technological advances things like
miniaturization and integration that we
see happening in a lot of types of
technologies sensors microprocessors
motor control and so on they're also
sort of approaches to innovation like
open innovation and open source these
are important because they're basically
helping us spread knowledge and
understanding of not just the sentence
itself but how to make the tools and
have them use the tools and by basically
getting on the same page and a lot of
these fields because we can spread
information about them so much
quickly we really become more of a
global integrated team and global
collaborators in a way this that we
haven't been able to get in the past and
then there's also new business models so
these are ways that we can get
information into users hands and into
new fields like you know companies from
universities or corporations by creating
startups and finding them with
crowd-sourced money or with venture
capital and accelerators and type of
business that essentially tastes
startups and help them get over the the
really mundane hurdles that have kept a
lot of startups from getting to market
in the past just basic things
Noli services and so on but also I guess
about how to design things to be
manufactured to scale how to market a
business and have to sell a product the
inventors don't have a new skill step so
all of these enablers on one side
they've been evolving from the past to
the future have been driving some
results in lab automation that we can
see in a couple different stages so
first it was really just about lower
Austin better Harney productivity a lab
animation was a way to automate the work
very expensive highly educated highly
paid researchers and essentially also in
some of the
having to do that was preparing or
recording information in Aladdin book
I'm just basic tasks that you know most
industries with a be banking or
manufacturing work or music you know all
these industries have benefited from
automation and unusually music it's
ending a greater accessibility in the
demonisation science that's really
related to what I was saying about open
innovation and open source well those
are really terms they come from another
field the move to print open science is
also very important in a catalyst that
works with those three factors and
basically it's bringing a lot more
people into the scientific field more
scientists alive today I think in all of
history combined the status heard so
must be true I heard it on the internet
I think but anyway there are a lot
people doing science today it is the
ability to do science has been
considerably where we are right now I'd
say the current state of the art is
around consistency so in a lot of
scientific fields and biology in
particular there's a crisis be produced
and basically what that means is that
two people doing the same experiment
following the same protocol don't always
get the same results some of the caring
the nature of biology and some of its
just because of avoidable factors and
automation and the consistency that the
data and in other types of automation
tools you can bring really helps reduce
some of that inconsistency and then
what's next for the future I think what
we're seeing is this basically
scientific frontier in other words
completely new measurements and
calculations things that we can't really
measure today or don't understand the
back up and towards the end of this
presentation I'll touch on one really
interesting future area which is quantum
computing and the ability it might give
us to to do modeling and analysis of
biological data and lab data you know
more rapid use bigger data sets and
other things so enablers in the results
driving yeah and they should allow what
I mean
um well you know why is it happening
like what's what's this specific thing
that's driving it and it's it's pretty
simple it's actually what's happening in
a lot of other fields lab tools are just
following office tool and reporting the
instruments sort of music media and a
lot of other things the baby they're
basically becoming information
technology and so if you go back to the
you know the eighties when we started
getting desktop there's really were
literally mentor of these typewriters
they were all tools and that's why
companies like IBM and Xerox that were
in the space put a lot of effort into
becoming information technology
companies and all there's an obvious
component to of information to science
we haven't always thought about
scientific tools as information
technology we think of them as
scientific instruments we think the
process is something that's you know
something about disparity but the rise
of omics so genomics and informatics or
bioinformatics for example that's really
transforming science and scientific
tools into information technologies so
if you look at something like more
flawed exponential or say the experience
curve about increasing performance of
chips and computers that's kind of
become synonymous with rapid exponential
and we're making any so we'll talk about
Moore's law in cars or things that
really have nothing at all to do with
the original law itself and that's
actually true in a lot of the fields so
as we've you know IG startups breaking
more and more industries and making new
ones again journalism and retail a bunch
of other areas that's really what's
happening it's trying to happen in the
scientific field and for the same
reasons so it's basically the
information Automation and open source
that has driven this in software and in
the electronic part later and those two
things have pervaded all kinds of field
so things that used to not offer like
again let's say the music recording
industry as though became
digitized in a lot of ways that
transform the stream ate something
different out of it and brought new
people and deplane yeah that's what's
happening right now in science and
that's one of the reasons we see a group
so DIY bio for example and others where
are people that have certainly a
technical background but don't always
have access to all the tools normally
get in a big lab at a university or a
company we're doing really really
interesting scientific innovation making
some breakers um they would do have
access to those those tools there's why
are we spending so much money and why
are we basically having what's you know
becoming quickly technology when there
is a field of innovation that's bringing
a lot more things to bear the the
innovation is coming out of all of these
fields in from office not more
scientific instrumentation and lab
automation um has two big impacts
one is feeds and market no only for the
tools Elspeth people are making so it's
its ability to come up with hypotheses
tested iterate revise and test it again
this driving speed to market in other
words that just things that process take
weeks or months or even years and now I
can take hours or days the other thing
that's really remarkable is the breadth
of products so in the past it just be
very much you know what you started
looking at in terms of say a medical
molecule or something was for
agricultural biotech was the only way it
the only place you'd find a product or
an application of that that research
today more and more these tools are
providing what you'd call a platform
ability in other words you develop
something that then can create lots and
lots of different cancer products so
companies like ginkgo Bioworks and
amorous do everything if you will see
agricultural chemicals two flavors and
scents that the really fundamental
platform ability also expressed to a lot
of other startups I'm not just outside
of biology but in it so we're looking at
now consumer products foods
personal care products and things like
that that we never would have thought of
a biological rather biotech but because
these tools are successful and so it's
applicable in a wide range of fields and
products actually stainless go that can
be addressed with biotechnology so at
these things are in lamps as I said
earlier we often use Moore's law as a
metaphor for something painting really
really fast but biological technologies
and instruments for fading them are
evolving even more quickly and so the
approved Moore's law for biotech is
called Carlson curves on Rob Carson I
started noticing this in the specific in
available DNA sequencing and synthesis
instruments and so he started basically
plotting the productivity of those tools
both in terms of time and cost go back
to the 70s when a lot of them were
invented to the human genome project and
today we have dozens companies bring I
field and in fact the pace of
improvement in those instruments is
faster than what we're seeing Jeff so
it's actually a Moore's law and they're
too broadly speaking two aspects of of
this so that's not just automation and
it's not just a tool that moves faster
it's also information our ability to
capturing this information means
expanding and we can do that in a
rigorous way with these tools we can
also share and spread them which again
which brings more people to the table
and it helps us to process a lot of
things in parallel the automation can
also helps in that it reduces but not
only the time it also the skill and get
to do a lot of Biological tasks so in
the past it would be you would need
depend um maybe you know months given
years learning to perfect a certain
technique just on on the ability to use
your hands with the ability to identify
markers you know a sample using you know
just using your hot and the tools are
getting much better at actually using
machine vision or robotics to automate
physical and mental tasks so that these
tools to see patterns that we needed to
till the time to do on our own over long
so drink you know the lab of Technology
I'm sorry the lab tomorrow and its
technologies down into a few categories
and specific things that we can start to
look at that
isn't exhaustive but I think it's
actually a pretty comprehensive picture
of the areas that are important at the
end today so on the information side
there's by had computer-aided design and
cloud bio limbs so allowed formation
management systems the to the
information technology software types of
things that you're driving I'm on the
other number of things you know again
physical things like DNA synthesis and
Christopher and so on but for today's
talk they're definitely automation I
just want to focus on open source lab
equipment
advances in a lot of different forms of
lab a'course but open source I think is
really the area where we see the fastest
and you know most widespread
breakthroughs and I'll go into each of
these in turn
so I'm by ok I start n stands for
computer aided design and cat actually
started in things like architecture and
you know mechanical types of engineering
but more recently it's coming to biology
and so we're basically we take the same
types of tools we have a an in silico
that is in the in computer model of a
processor of an object and that model
corresponds its behavior in the computer
correspond to accurately to its behavior
in the real world that we can strive to
do things like simulation iteration and
permutation online or again in the
computer so we don't have to do it in
the real world so the same way we don't
have to you know crash test cards from
from the first product
we can develop prototypes and then when
we are pretty sure we figured out all
the most biggest problems we can
actually crash just physical cars we can
do the same things
io CAD those we use the these tools to
automate the design of let's say a gene
and we can model its extent and the
results of that event mutations Rima I
mean you got a pretty good picture of
how that's gonna work a lot more quickly
than we can do that if we were to
actually they put that beam into a
microcosm and then find culture it and
see what the results were so not only
does it automate engineering work
identify early errors early on there is
no reasoning or Eric in our process it
can also help with permutation so again
let's say that you have an idea about
one mutation and how that might play out
in the biological system with with
biocad systems you can actually have it
generate mutations that you either might
not have had time to you or might not
have had the knowledge to do and then
run those systems also also through a
virtual virtual simulation so those
things really help begin accelerate the
development of biological organs and
tools and there are in addition to the
tools themselves a couple of really
interesting integrations we've seen so
the modeling on its own has some you
know well has it's it's it's limited in
other words it's one step in where
there's always a much longer process so
we're seeing company it's engraved that
ability with other steps in the process
so a tomb which used to be called DNA
2.0 started actually synthesizing genes
they developed some software CAD
front-end basically to be their customer
interface so it's kind of like you know
if you go buy a car you might figure it
online question and you order it that's
really similar to what they've done
they've developed tools so that you can
test out what you what you think is
gonna work in DNA on a virtual
environment and then when you know
you've got new candidate chosen you can
actually order them and they'll send you
the actual plasmids with those two
sequences you
you've discovered another example is
benchlink so finishing also makes some
of this type of distance offer but what
they've looked at is the increasing
reliance on collaboration so in the past
again a lot of people were sort of you
know on their own or didn't necessarily
have the ability to easily share work
with anybody outside of their specific
lab but now with collaboration becoming
so what you know pricing institution or
even across the world the ability to
integrate collaborative tools with with
every task is important so so they've
been looking moving to buy em study and
his laboratory information management
systems electronic local notebooks are
one aspect of that but those systems
actually been around for quite a long
time a bit too changes the bio and the
cloud have really helped exploit their
youth their usefulness and their
adoption um so again in the past
laboratory information systems were used
for things like you know keeping track
of how many reagents were how much
various regions was left in inventory or
who is doing what experiments on a
machine at certain times of scheduling
and pretty mundane types of things the
addition of logical tip that essentially
meant that these from be just a very
custom customized to biological data and
often integrated with the instruments
that were capturing it so rather than
having to look at the display right in a
lab number and then go type it up in the
lymph system all that that data flow
from the instrument into this new system
is automated at these days and again
adjusted or customized for bio cloud
basically means that it's it's in the
shared system from the big thing so as
improvements to the software are made
they're instantly available to all the
users and similarly as data is acquired
it's also available to everybody who has
access to that data through the cloud
system so the these changes you know get
happen in a lot of other areas think of
your banking and other types of
industries that are doing this for quite
a while in fact that it's coming to me
too - bio lab automation similar impacts
where you know we have a lot more
automated back-office and front office
work in those industries and that could
similarly affect how we how we do how we
do algae the in addition to just the the
workflow improvements it also has the
benefit that we can all even get access
to faster faster processors and a lot
more data storage so high-end tools
d-level and against some things that are
just kind of practical aspects of what's
happened in IT and a lot of other
industries for a long time my personal
view though one that a lot of people
would would share is that the real
critical aspect of this that's specific
and unique to biotechnology is the
crisis of Irabu produced ability but
your irreducible results and that's
basically does you know a lot of times
we'll have as I mentioned earlier will
have a protocol that's published in a
paper you'll read that paper and we'll
try and follow it and you just don't get
the same results and it's really
frustrating hard to understand because
probably why there are a lot of reasons
for this and some of it is again just
due to experimental noise the inherent
nature of biology every organism is a
little bit different from every other
one and sometimes there's just actually
matter it's also just a difference in
technique or a lack of information about
for example what temperature something
to store that or other conditions that
were maybe just you know seems like
irrelevant details so the person who
originally did the experiment but are
actually very important now and in fact
the outcome of the experiment so those
tears are greatly aided by by bio limbs
and to companies that really this very
dry cover and riffin and they I think do
a huge service by starting the new
experiments dearie and helping
researchers actually document how
they're going to experiments and set
them up in an ounce of running them so
that helps them run the experiment more
a logical way but it also helps with
documentation they're also quite a
number these that are working on limbs
integrated robots so Emeralds that they
go and few of those but here again the
ability to use this threat to guide the
hardware the robotics is really critical
we give you you lemonade a lot of that
error that results from you know one
researcher versus another actually doing
the experiment and the robots in the
best case are actually gonna do it
consistently not only every single time
in a certain lab but also from one lab
to another so open source like a lot of
[Music]
flavors so there's open source software
open source hardware and increasing the
open source science there are a lot of
areas of science where it better to have
a large number of sources of of data and
and so when sort of sign it's basically
help best then the designs tend for open
source science and that idea of sharing
is also coming to hardware and software
outside well on the edges of science so
Arduino microcontrollers RepRap 3d
printers cue stats these are as an open
standard for designing satellites and
now we have a bunch of very inexpensive
satellites and already using that
standard
lower the cost to expand the user base
and and that basically helps improve the
tools performance and cost further as
more people come in
so check out and open Tron's are two
examples
Meishan in PCR depending respectively
but a lot of companies that are bringing
to market are now taking this approach
essentially it has a lot of advantages
in terms of getting to market and
getting products into people's hands at
a lower cost and more broadly so I
mentioned earlier quantum computing and
I want to say you know it's I would love
to say it's next it's not quite next and
I don't want to give a little overview
of what common computing is and and when
I think it'll actually available based
on you you know you need online and some
papers but also when I've learned
talking with the experts on both sides
both the user and the developer side of
quantum machines I would be basic you
know about quantum computing is that
whereas normal computers use bits so one
or zero
quantum computers use qubits so if you
think of it's this sphere over here
which is a way to keep it you're often
depicted normally you would have a one
say you know her pointing straight north
or in zero the arrow pointing straight
South Cubans actually give you a
superposition of all of the possible
directions of that arrow which of course
wants to basic with different
probabilities between that one and then
zero and what that means picks occurring
in practical terms is that whereas a
normal computer image we could have to
crunch through all the permutations of
ones and zeros one by one a quantum
computer because of the substrate that
uses for calculation can actually get
all of those possibilities at the same
time so that belief are two brief
introduction I encourage you to look
into the basis if one of computing if
you want to know more about the
implication of that as we could do very
complex calculations very quickly and so
in chemistry obvious chemistry and
biochemistry there have been a lot of
papers and you know even in nature and
and other high-profile public a talk
about how
quickly quantum computing is going to be
solving these chemistry problems richard
fineman
and also set the nature is quantum and
if we're gonna solve it and we're gonna
need okay so the reality though again
just based on locations recently with
the developers and users of these is
that it's been quite a long way from
being that it's even modeling say a
three atom molecule is kind of at the
edge of what's he conceived when I was
today's quantum computers and with other
computers that could take off in the
future but it will are going at least
for the next few years where three or
four atom molecules might be the most
complex things that we can model but
after that hopefully it will take off
and maybe in the you know only five to
2030 timeframe we'll have some amazing
tools from service that's a little bit
farther out than the s1 we need to
normally consider so if you are in lab
instrumentation and computation yes
you're computing and how I could get
impact your business but if you that I
think that the user it's definitely
worth it to wait a few years for about
how that could be your your science so
to wrap this all up then how can you get
started if these are areas you're
interested in I would say look at
investor I break our labs with the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation both of the
VIP billionaires but they're really
trying out some of the I think some of
the most interesting new things in
automation both in tools and in using
them
there are accelerators like qb3 garage
and you see a staff while Combinator
which is a very famous IT accelerator
has recently added a biotech track Indy
bio alumina until there's a lot more
focus on those things
there are hacker spaces like gen space
and bio curious counterculture lab in
Oakland there's the gym that's
internationally genetically engineered
machines competition crowdfunding versus
IndieGoGo has been reopened to
biological and both tools and and
organisms whereas cancer actually had
some biological organisms
they said I'm doing that again but but
there's innovation happening there and
then their events so I mentioned I Jim
is actually a competition hackerspace
per se but it's a competition for
students and then an event called
sympathy ADA
that's held will be held in San
Francisco later this year in October and
this will bring together a lot of the
community about the hardware developers
and the users for these technologies so
there's a lot going on and the most
immediate way to get started is to send
questions so we have time for a few
questions here today and you can also
follow with me either through the the
labyrinth tool or directly on email
thank you very much thank you marking on
your corner we will now start the rides
to my question of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
first question is there are a lot of
little companies in this space
how will they compete with the agilent's
and thermal fissures of the world really
good question and it's true companies
are really scrappy and small and they
don't look like sort of the Goliath even
aside the David they would take on a
Goliath but what happens over time is
that these tools get get better and
improve and it's very similar I think to
what's happened in other industries
where you know a low-cost competitor
initially starts out only being
applicable for for amateurs and students
but over time it improves and really
becomes you know the industry standard
not only because it improves but also
because the people that have been using
it become more and more senior and more
adept at using them but other way it's
just through acquisition so
these tools often really again start out
of small companies and small companies
get acquired so you've seen this in a
lot of different areas with Life
Technologies and Agilent and others
actually acquiring some of the software
and hardware that other people have
developed one of the things I think is
really interesting I diluted to this in
the conversation is that it's sometimes
is you know it's definitely companies
you'd expect like in in say Pharma or in
AG AG tech but these tools have really
broaden the appeal and the relevance of
biologically based materials into
industries that really wouldn't have had
anything to do with it in the past so
one example from you know about ten
years ago is fuels and energy the global
warming and the the war in Iraq and a
bunch of other things were happening
about ten years ago though in the oil
price also at the time spurred a lot of
interest in using biologic resource
materials and biological processes to
create fuels and then also other types
of substitutes for petroleum products so
again back in with the oil price being
you know well north of $100 a barrel the
people developed biological ways to make
really almost anything we would get from
petroleum ad costs that were competitive
at that price so oil prices have been
creeping up again and the opportunity to
do those things might come back but in
the meantime there are other things that
they're actually much more high-value
products that I wouldn't have expected
to see as biological back man and those
again can be you know things like food
and personal care products things that
are you know very intimately close to
robot Bazin that a regulatory pathway
that hasn't conventionally and
geared up for providing that's exactly
what's happening right now as if people
are starting to look at how can we
regulate and approve these products as
they move to market and that's happening
more quickly a lot of that is driven by
the the economics but a lot of it's also
by the people's shifting desires and
other words wanting to have more natural
products and wanting to use more
biologically based things than those
from from other more synthetic chemical
means exciting yeah I think the future
by definition is exciting
so I'd say one area that I think is a
great I should say one trend I'm seeing
is a use of artists so artists in
residence there are a number of
institutions and organizations that we
wouldn't normally think of it it's very
very scientific the Devonian artists to
help them see new possibilities with the
work and the tools that they're they're
developing so outside of bio SETI the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
has an artist-in-residence program
there's a guy named Scott killed all
there who's basically working with their
data and their tools to expand their
understanding of what they've got within
biotech ginko Bioworks and company
modern meadow have faces we've been
using artists to help them explore you
know what new products and services they
might do in the future how people might
react to those look at how they might be
designed to be more appealing there's an
artist named Lucy McCrae who well she's
not a biological artist herself she's
been using sort of the ideas and tools
for biology to look at things like you
know what if you could swallow a pill
that would help you make your own
perfume or you know what if you could
essentially bro the things that your
body needed specifically at a certain
time based on your own your own sales so
so these concepts you know they can be
very abstract but then when an artist
gets them and sort of puts them into
just envisions them basically and does a
little bit of the work not only about
thinking but developing them to make
them happen
you know it seems a lot more tangible
when we've seen you know many many times
in the past where the tricorder on Star
Trek is sort of inspired the first
mobile phones and things like that so I
think looking to art as a way to see the
future before other people do is a
really good good approach for his
presentation I'd also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through August 31st 2018 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
a replay we share that announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye